or Patricia hi
Patricia where'd you grow up where are
you from originally mrb Arizona
Phoenix's Hospital
tell me about your family growing up
um I love my family until I was 18. it's
Tyler qtl and then I ended up at a
shelter down at Cash shelter in Phoenix
Arizona
and ever since I've been homeless I'm 35
pretty soon and um I'm really excited
for being here so let's have a deal you
got kicked out at what age
18 years old what was going on that you
got kicked out
um they didn't want me there no more so
they asked me to leave
but why did you get kicked out because
they couldn't accept me no more I had no
more funding for me
was there anything you were doing that
might have
caused I was drinking
I was drinking too and I was doing drugs
and then I left
and I was pursuing and acting care that
was not what's going to happen but
um it started happening and they asked
me to leave and that's what happened and
then I went on to
modeling her and I was going to Milan
for five years I made some money and
then the modeling care didn't accept me
no more so I left the line with her and
I've been on the street since I've been
in a homeless shelters I've been in a
voucher program or I had an apartment
for a year in a housing yet
what is your drug
um
see
could you guessed that
well that's what I use that's what I
like and that's what I do yeah
how do you make money
um I gotta work the street corner asked
for money ask for help
meeting like doing dates with guys or
yeah yeah dates yeah
and also I asked for money I asked for
help just whatever I do whatever you can
do to get money yeah I asked for money I
don't really do dates so much
um I just asked for money probably
McDonald's or can talk about or
somewhere like that
where are you staying on the streets
yeah I'm homeless
how long have you been like that
um since I was 18 I'm almost 35.
you have kids no
not married anything like that no you
talk to your family anymore
um not really anymore nope
it won't help me at all so I don't talk
to him at all
do you have any friends or anything no
I'll just myself it's just you and your
pursuit of Crystal man
yeah do you think um I can come back in
a half hour and we can finish up the
conversation
sure what do you need to do I was gonna
go see my friend and then ask someone to
drop it off for a half hour and see if
we can finish it up
tell you what just give me another
minute or two and then we'll be done
okay bye
um
do you have any regrets in your life no
I don't
I don't have any guys um I take every
second by a second and I believe that
every second is Right everything I get
is right to me and I love it and I love
life and I love everything about life I
love that California too after I get out
here three days ago so beautiful I love
it out here
I'll just hit your life become a nurse
possibly and that's the truth
you want to become a nurse yes
you might have to put down the speed
though yeah definitely what's your
biggest fear now
I'm not having any money at all
to take care of myself
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um containing money
consuming money
you have any good memories of your
childhood
um yeah I always play around with parks
or in our Parks playing around it's the
best memory ever was there anyone else
in your family that was involved in
drugs or addiction no just you yeah
your family doesn't take it very well no
um
sorry
would you like to be in five years
um was a job as a nurse
um or in a college teaching for nursing
are you going to put down the drugs uh
I'm gonna stop
do you think
um
I can't I well
all right John one more question what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your 35 years
um probably
um getting a career it's the most
hardest part of signing in school
and that's continuous I'm looking
all right John thank you for stopping by
okay you're welcome
did I earn any money at all